GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
ANDREW MCCABE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
RETIRED RIGHT NOW.
HE HAD SERVED IN THE FBI FOR
MORE THAN TWO DECADES AND ROSE
TO BE THE BUREAU'S DEPUTY
DIRECTOR.
ON FRIDAY NIGHT AROUND
10:00 P.M. EASTERN, HE WAS
STRIPPED OF HIS FEDERAL PENSION
48 HOURS BEFORE IT WAS SET TO
KICK IN.
FIRED BY ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS FOR "LACK OF CANDOR
UNDER OATH ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS."
PRESIDENT TRUMP, A LONE CRITIC
OF McCABE, CALLED IT A GREAT
DAY FOR DEMOCRACY.
McCABE MAINTAINS HE WAS SACKED
TO UNDERMINE THE GRID ABILITY OF
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INVESTIGATION.
HE HAS TURNED OVER MEMOS OF HIS
CONVERSATION WITH
PRESIDENT ROBERT MUELLER STEAM.
THERE IS A FIRESTORM OF REACTION
THERE IS A FIRESTORM OF REACTIO
REACTION.
>> AND THE PRESIDENT SAID IS A
GREAT DAY FOR DEMOCRACY
YESTERDAY, I THINK IT'S A
HORRIBLE DAY FOR DEMOCRACY.
TO HAVE FIRINGS LIKE THIS
HAPPENING AT THE TOP FROM THE
PRESIDENT, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
IT DOES NOT SPEAK WELL FOR WHAT
IS GOING ON.
>> HIS FIRING MAY BE JUSTIFIED.
THERE'S NO WAY FOR US TO KNOW AT
THIS POINT.
EVEN THOUGH IT MAY HAVE BEEN
JUSTIFIED, CAN ALSO BE TAINTED.
IT WAS CLEARLY RUSHED, AND I
THINK THEIR QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
AND WHETHER THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PUTTING PRESSURE ON THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO TAKE THIS
ACTION.
IT APPEARS TO HAVE      HAVE BEE
IT APPEARS TO HAVE      HAVE BEN
COMPRESSED IN ORDER TO TAKE
VENGEANCE ON THIS GUY.
>> ANDREW MCCABE DESTROYED HIS
CREDIBILITY ALL BY HIMSELF.
>> Jesse: FORMER DIRECTOR JOHN
BRENNAN DIDN'T HOLD BACK DISDAIN
FOR MR. TRUMP.
"WHEN THE FULL EXTENT OF YOUR
VENALITY AND MORAL TURPITUDE AND
POLITICAL CORRUPTION BECOMES
KNOWN, YOU WILL TAKE YOUR
RIGHTFUL PLACE AS A DISGRACED
DEMAGOGUE IN THE DUSTBIN OF
HISTORY."
A LITTLE OVER THE TOP THERE.
WHEN I FOUND INTERESTING IS IN
THE MONTAGE, ADAM SCHIFF, A
PRETTY PARTISAN DEMOCRAT.
HE SAYS IT COULD BE A
POSSIBILITY THIS FIRING OF
McCABE WAS COMPLETELY
JUSTIFIED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Kimberly: THAT TELLS ME
EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW.
HE WOULDN'T BE SAYING ANYTHING
LIKE THAT THAT MIGHT DISPLACE
HIS PARTISAN BASE TO THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RUNNING AMOK
HERE.
SAYING THAT TELLS ME HE HAS
KNOWLEDGE AND INFORMATION TO
SUGGEST IN FACT IT WAS
JUSTIFIED.
I DON'T THINK HE WOULD GO OUT OF
THERE WAY TO DO IT IF THEY
DIDN'T HAVE GOOD REASON AND FULL
COSTS.
IN FACT, THE PEOPLE MAKING THE
RECOMMENDATION, THE PEOPLE WHO
WORK WITH HIM AT THE FBI.
YOU BROUGHT A HUMANITARIAN POINT
TO IT LAST WEEK.
YOU SAID IT'S TWO DAYS BEFORE
THE GUY'S.
LOOK AT THAT ASPECT OF IT.
NEVERTHELESS, THE FACTS ARE
THERE, PERSUASIVE AND COMPELLING
THERE, PERSUASIVE AND COMPELLIN
COMPELLING.
>> Jesse: JUAN, PEOPLE ARE
SAYING IF IT WAS JUST A REGULAR
GUY IN THE FBI OUT THE FIELD AND
HE DID WHAT McCABE DID, HE
WOULD BE TREATED THE EXACT SAME
WAY.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT ARGUMENT?
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THAT'S
TRUE.
BUT I UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT.
I THINK WHAT'S TRUEST FBI AGENTS
ARE NOT RICH PEOPLE AND THEY
REALLY RELY ON PENSIONS.
TYPICALLY THERE'S A LOT OF
LEEWAY GIVEN, ESPECIALLY WHEN
THERE'S TWO DAYS AGO.
I THINK WHAT HAPPENED HERE IS WE
DON'T KNOW.
YOU'RE SEEING ADAM SCHIFF SAY IT
COULD BE THAT ADAM SCHIFF IS
PROTECTING HIMSELF FROM POSSIBLE
BLOWBACK.
IF YOU GET A REPORT FROM THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL THAT INDICATES
McCABE EITHER LIED OR WAS NOT
FORTHCOMING WITH THEM, THEN YOU
SAY OKAY, SO THERE WAS
JUSTIFICATION FOR IT?
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT McCABE
HAS SAID THAT'S NOT TRUE.
HE EITHER WAS IN CHAOS AND WAS
MISUNDERSTOOD.
HE SAYS HE DID NOT LIE OR
MISLEAD THEM.
THAT'S ALL WE HAVE ON THE TABLE
AT THE MOMENT.
GIVEN THE JAMES COMEY FIRING INI
GIVEN THE JAMES COMEY FIRING INN
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
SAYING RUSSIA, THEY DID IN
DONALD TRUMP, IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THIS, YOU CAN'T
IGNORE THE POLITICS.
AND THE POLITICS ARE STINKY.
>> Jesse: OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF
POLITICS IN WASHINGTON.
TO BE EXPECTED, DANA.
DO YOU THINK IT WAS A LITTLE
HARSH?
DO YOU THINK INTERNAL
INVESTIGATORS THINK HE DID A BAD
THING?
>> Dana: I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THEM FULL REPORT BEFORE MAKING A
DETERMINATION.
WITHOUT THAT WE ARE BASICALLY
GOING ON GUT INSTINCT TO WHAT WE
HEAR ABOUT WHAT MIGHT'VE BEEN
LINKED OR NOT.
-- LEAKED OR NOT.
IF THE PRESIDENT HADN'T TWEETED
ABOUT THIS ON SATURDAY MORNING,
RUBBING McCABE'S FACE IN IT,
THE STORY LINE WOULD'VE BEEN THE
WHOLE WEEKEND IS THE OFFICE OF
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY
RECOMMENDED THIS FIRING.
THAT I THINK WOULD'VE BEEN A
NICE FACE TO LEAVE IT RIGHT
THERE.
LET EVERYBODY TALK ABOUT THE
OFFICE OF RESPONSE          PROE
OFFICE OF RESPONSE          PROS
OFFICE OF RESPONSE          PROO
OFFICE OF RESPONSE          PROA
OFFICE OF RESPONSE          PROL
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Greg: MY FIRST THOUGHT IS,
DANA'S HAIR LOOKS GREAT.
>> Dana: THANKS, EVERYONE.
>> Jesse: I WAS MORE PAYING
ATTENTION TO WHAT SHE WAS
SAYING.
>> Greg: THE WEIRD THING HERE
IS JOHN BRENNAN'S MANIFESTO OF A
TWEET.
ALMOST WRITTEN AS PART OF A
"WEST WING" SCRIPT LEFT OVER.
AFTER HE SAYS THAT, THIS
MAGICAL, MANICURED STUFF,
SAMANTHA POWER RETWEETS AND
WRITES "YOU DON'T WANT TO GET
THIS GUY ANGRY."
IT'S LIKE BEING IN A HIGH SCHOOL
CAFETERIA.
THE CHEERLEADER SAYS LET ME HOLD
YOUR JACKET.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET INTO FIGHT.
MAYBE THAT IS A SUBMISSION THAT
HILLARY KEEPS TALKING ABOUT.
IT'S HIS ANGER.
IT REFLECTS THE DEEP ANIMOSITY
THAT VALIDATES TRUMP'S
ASSUMPTIONS AND ASSERTIONS ABOUT
PEOPLE IN POWER WHO WANT HIM
GONE.
THAT IS THE HOOD ORNAMENT.
THE TWEET IS THE HOOD ORNAMENT
OF ALL THESE PEOPLE WHO
SINCERELY BELIEVE THERE'S A BAD
MAN IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT IS THE CIRCLE OF MEDIA AND
THE TRUMP CRITICS AND THEY MATCH
PERFECTLY.
SELF-PERPETUATING ENGINE OF
PANIC TO THE MEDIA SAYS OH, MY
GOD.
HE'S EVIL.
THEN YOU HAVE THIS DUDE AND YOU
HAVE COMEY AND THE OTHER GUY AND
THIS GUY WHO WERE IN THE
GOVERNMENT SAYING THE SAME
THING.
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE.
THE MEDIA, I GUESS YOU WOULD
CALL THEM WASHINGTON INSIDERS OR
ESTABLISHMENT, WHATEVER.
THE REACTIONS ARE 99.9%
IDENTICAL.
THAT'S WHERE YOU GET THE
HYSTERIA AND THE PANIC BECAUSE
THERE IS NO YOU NINE      -- NO
THERE IS NO YOU NINE      -- NOI
THERE IS NO YOU NINE      -- NON
THERE IS NO YOU NINE      -- NOD
YANG.
WHEN IT IS THIS UNIFORM AND
HYSTERICAL, IT MAKES ME THINK
IT'S EMOTIONALLY DRIVEN.
>> Jesse: UNIFORM WAS THE
REACTION TO THIS AND EVERYBODY
SAID THE NEXT APP, MUELLER IS
GONE.
LET'S HEAR SOME OF THAT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE DESIGNS
ARE ON MUELLER BUT IT SEEMS TO
BE BUILDING TOWARD THAT.
I HOPE IT DOESN'T GO THERE.
BECAUSE IT CAN'T.
WE CAN'T IN CONGRESS EXCEPT
THAT.
>> HE TRIED TO DO THAT, IT WOULD
BE THE BEGINNING OF THE END OF
HIS PRESIDENCY BECAUSE WE ARE A
RULE OF LAW OR NATION.
>> I WOULD HOPE IT WOULD PROMPT
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS IN THE
HOUSE TO PASS AN INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL LAW AND REINSTATE BOB
MUELLER.
THIS WOULD UNDOUBTEDLY IS OFTEN
A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
I THINK DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS NEED TO SPEAK OUT
ABOUT THIS RIGHT NOW.
>> Jesse: KIMBERLY, DO YOU
BELIEVE THERE IS MOMENTUM
BUILDING FOR FIRING MUELLER OR
IS IT A SELF PERPETUATION OF THE
MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS WHERE
THEY ALMOST WANT THIS TO HAPPEN.
>> Kimberly: A LITTLE BIT OF
THE SELF PERPETUATION
MERRY-GO-ROUND.
THE ONE YOU WANT TO GET OFF OF
BEFORE YOU THROW UP.
I DON'T THINK IS GOING TO MAKE A
MOVE LIKE THAT.
I THINK IT WOULD BE ILL-ADVISED
AT THIS POINT TO DO SOMETHING
LIKE THAT, GIVEN THIS HAS
ALREADY GONE SO FAR DOWN THE
ROAD.
LET THEM COMPLETE THE
INVESTIGATION.
I DON'T SEE ANY UPSIDE FOR THE
PRESIDENT IN REMOVING HIM AT
THIS JUNCTURE.
THE ONLY DOWNSIDE IS TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF FALLOUT AND CRITICISM.
WE SAW THAT WHEN THAT HAPPENED
WITH COMEY.
WE DON'T THINK THIS SHOULD
FOLLOW IN THE FOOTSTEPS.
YOU HAVE McCABE GONE.
DO THE INVESTIGATION, COMPLETED,
COME TO THE CONCLUSION.
SEE IT THROUGH, ALL THE WAY
THROUGH FRUITION.
>> Juan: >> Juan: THIS IN
>> Juan: >> Juan: THIS IT
>> Juan: >> Juan: THIS IE
>> Juan: >> Juan: THIS IF
>> Juan: >> Juan: THIS IR
>> Juan: >> Juan: THIS IT
TIME THE PRESIDENT HAS MAYBE
THOUGHT ABOUT FIRING MUELLER.
THEY WERE REPORTS IN JANUARY
THAT HE'S BEEN THINKING ABOUT
IT.
PEOPLE SAY NO, HE WOULD NEVER DO
THAT IT WAS CONFIRMED THAT IN
FACT HE WAS THINKING OF DOING
JUST THAT.
AND NOW AGAIN WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
THIS WEEKEND, I THOUGHT HE WAS
MANIC IN THE TWEETS, THE ATTACKS
ON THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY,
FBI.
>> Greg: IT WAS A DEFLECTION.
TRUMP WAS TWEETING SO YOU DIDN'T
NOTICE HE WAS COLLUDING WITH
PUTIN TO ENACT THE ELECTION IN
RUSSIA.
I WANTED TO GIVE YOU A NEW
CONSPIRACY.
HELPING PUT IN BECOME PRESIDENT
FOR LIFE.
THE BEST PART IS, AND I KNOW YOU
HATE THE WORD VIRTUE SIGNALING,
TWO WORDS.
ALL THE PEOPLE OFFERING TO PAY
THE PENSION FOR McCABE OR PAY
FOR THE NEXT THING, THEY CARE SO
MUCH ABOUT A QUESTIONABLE
BUREAUCRATS PENSION THAT ACTUAL
REAL SUFFERING.
>> Jesse: GOOD POINT.
>> Greg: WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: HERE'S WHAT I WOULD
SAY.
A LITTLE BIT OF ADVICE.
I WAS THE SPOKESPERSON FOR
KARL ROVE DURING THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO FIGURE
OUT THE LEGAL STRATEGY AND THE
COMMUNICATION STRATEGY BUT THEY
REALLY MUST WORK IN TANDEM.
IT'S A TERRIBLE IDEA FOR THE
LAWYERS TO BE OUT FRONT AND NOT
IN COMMUNICATION OR COORDINATION
WITH THE P.R. PEOPLE.
THE OTHER THING THAT HAPPENED
THIS WEEKEND, THIS PAST WEEK,
YOU HAD REPORTS THAT QUESTIONS
FROM THE MUELLER TEAM HAD GONE
TO TRUMP'S LAWYERS, THEY SAID
THINGS WE MIGHT WANT TO ASK HIM
IF WE WERE TO HAVE AN INTERVIEW.
NOW THE PRESIDENT KNOWS WHAT
THAT IS.
THERE'S A SUBPOENA TO THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION.
THERE IS McCABE'S FIRING.
THE DOWD COMMENTS ABOUT HOW THEY
SHOULD ALL END.
YES, I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE PRESIDENT.
NO, I AM SPEAKING IN MY OWN
CAPACITY.
I DON'T BELIEVE ANY EVENT.
THEY HAVE TO GET THEIR P.R.
PEOPLE IN SYNC WITH THEIR LEGAL
PEOPLE OR THEY'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE NEWS CYCLES